[Musique]
c'est dans cette garderie bien spéciale
à val-d'or que magali et marie nous
développer leur complicité
vu qu'on a créé un lien d'amitié
vraiment je n ai pas une différence
cette différence c'est que magalie est
autochtone plus précisément anishnabe
fabien théorie jérôme 21 ans et
illustratrice elle a elle aussi grandi
en ville et fréquenté la même garderie
qui a contribué à forger son identité
culturelle
je pense pas que je serais aussi chaude
et and china b sujet gérard était là
aussi le c'est pour ces deux raisons que
michel serre jury a choisi d'envoyer son
fils dans la même garderie
on veut rentrer à la garderie pour lui
offrir un milieu sans préjugés et lui
permettre de s'approprier la culture
anishnabe le cpe abeano 10me guam qui
signifie la maison des enfants existe
depuis près de 20 ans c'est une garderie
mixte pour enfants autochtones et non
autochtones
michel des saints deux générations de
femmes ayant perdu leur statut
parce qu'elles ont marié un non
autochtone en permettant des médecins de
fréquenter la garderie ici il reçoit
beaucoup de demont en anishinabe des
choses que tout démons que moi j'ai
jamais pu apprendre pendant des
décennies le gouvernement canadien a
tenté d'assimiler les premières nations
et les inuit
fini le statut d'indien des cons marié
un non autochtone qu'on obtenait une
diplôme universitaire ou qu'on vivait en
dehors d'une réserve
c'est dans ce contexte que sont nées les
centres d'amitié autochtones
celui de val d'or a vu le jour en 1974
déménager et a grandi depuis
c'est le plus gros centres d'amitié
autochtones au québec et ce qui est
particulier des centres d'amitié bien
c'est des centres communautaires
autochtone qui ont vu le jour par des
autochtones pour les autochtones
une panoplie de services sont offerts
ici de l'aide aux itinérants et faire
vos ferrer une clinique santé bientôt
adapté pour les suivis de grossesse un
projet de logements abordables pour les
familles avec un service d aide aux
devoirs des distributions alimentaires
hebdomadaire pg et la gare de vie qui
fonctionne de façon indépendante mais
qui a été conçu par les gestionnaires du
centre d'amitié en majorité des femmes
et le cpa bino jimmy graham est née d'un
besoin d'abord et avant tout de famille
autochtone donc de plus en plus
nombreuses à s'établir en ville qu'ils
avaient des besoins de services de garde
à travers la mission même du centre qui
est aussi de favoriser le rapprochement
entre les peuples
donc par la lutte contre le racisme la
discrimination les préjugés ne saute la
barrière qui voit peau y en a pas de
barrière le tri mon ami qui soyez au top
tous nous pose le suppo monsieur duceppe
se courait que ça mon ami de cesser
c'est fluide c'est peu mais j'ai
toujours mon ancienne vie j'ai travaillé
je travaillais dit tout ça je
travaillais à réparer des adultes puis
aujourd'hui je tripe à ma façon
construire des enfants se trouvent se
prend un génial je vais pleurer tu crois
pêle-mêle mais moi je ne savais rien
prévilégié là dessus chose certaine
magali mary lee ont forgé une amitié qui
défie le temps
moi je pense qu'il entraîne notre
génération est beaucoup plus ouverte
d'esprit que que les générations avant
nous ce sera un
je travaille j'utilise beaucoup de monde
m'a comme darty com moderne déjà g2 est
mon cousin fabienne elle termine un
projet de livre et rêve de concevoir des
personnages autochtone pour une série
télévisée pour enfants
c'est être anishnabe ça aussi dans ton
homme voit ça ça fait beaucoup lu mon
frère ben moi je rappelle que shaw dr
jamieson et mélodies n'ont pas encore
conscience d'être autochtone inonde
autochtone qu'importe ils sont à n'y a
ni tous les deux aînés mme lagarde qui
moyens nous fassent des prêts cola et
moi aussi j'aime faire des plis collage
et au vième dessiner ici julie marceau
radio canada val d'or